STEPHANIE WONG: As your
cloud number grows,
how do you connect each VPC
without the headache of setting
up a mountain of VPNs?
And don't get me started about
the performance overhead.
Well, there's a
brilliant feature
I'd like to introduce to you
to save you from all of that--
VPC Peering.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As a very hand-wavy
explanation, cloud providers
build their network with
a series of data centers
which they position around the
world in strategic locations.
Since there's already
internet topography,
they can rely on
the public internet
to deal with the connections
between these data centers
without having to do too much
additional lifting, which
is fine, but introduces a
large problem of security
for your data.
Any content from
the public internet
is vulnerable to all sorts
of behavior, not to mention
the performance issues, which
is why corporations utilize
virtual private networks, VPNs,
and virtual private clouds,
VPCs.
These allow customers
and employees
to securely access cloud
resources despite being
on the public internet.
Now, as your cloud footprint
grows and your team complexity
grows, one thing
that starts to happen
is something called
VPC islanding.
That is, as you start to enable
more data center regions to be
used by your service, you start
to get more and more complexity
overhead to bootstrap, manage,
and maintain these VPCs in each
of your regions.
Thankfully, Google Cloud has
an answer for this headache.
By default, all
VPCs on Google Cloud
are global, meaning
you don't need
to set up a VPC for each
region, which is pretty nice.
You get to build it
once and move on.
But this doesn't work
for every organization.
Some structures need
more fine-grained control
over VPC deployment,
effectively needing
to redeploy different VPCs
across different regions
for isolation purposes.
And for this, we need
to setup VPC peering.
This is useful in cases where
you have several network
administrative domains.
For example, you might have a
VPC for the finance department
and another for the
accounting department.
The finance department needs
access to all the resources
that are in their
accounting department,
and the accounting
department needs access
to all the resources in
the finance department.
Or imagine that you have two
VPCs connected via VPC peering,
and you'd like to
reach both of them
from an on-prem network
with a single VPN.
This is a very common use
case, as many managed services
and GCP use VPC peering,
including Cloud SQL.
Behind the scenes, VPC peering
uses our global virtual network
backbone to create a
connection by allowing networks
to exchange routes.
It isn't a gateway
or a VPN connection
and doesn't rely on a
separate piece of hardware
so that there's no single
point of failure or a bandwidth
bottleneck.
Let's walk through
setting up VPC peering.
What we're doing today
is creating a VPC
peering so a WordPress
deployment in one network
can communicate privately
with a MySQL deployment
in another network.
In this project, I have
two VPCs, VPC 1 and VPC 2,
with non-overlapping
IP ranges, and I want
to set up peering between them.
I've also deployed a WordPress
and MySQL instance in each VPC,
respectively.
To create a peering connection
between the two VPCs,
head to the VPC peering page
and click the Create Connection
button.
Click Continue,
then enter a name
for the peering connection,
and select the source
and destination networks.
This one is from VPC 1 to VPC 2.
While that's creating,
repeat the above process,
and create a second
peering connection,
this time reversing the
source and destination
networks, VPC 2 to VPC 1.
Once created, the two
networks will automatically
connect to each
other, and you'll
see a green check mark
confirming peering is active.
Over on the routing
page, you can
see it's automatically
created routes between the two
networks, and we now have
a full mesh topology.
Once the networks are
connected, the next step
is to configure the firewall
to enable traffic between them.
For security reasons,
you should only
allow access to
the specific ports
and from trusted
source IP addresses.
I've already created
a firewall rule
that allows TCP access
from the WordPress network
to the MySQL instance
on port 3306.
The next step is to ensure that
the deployments in the two VPCs
are able to communicate
with each other.
At the time of
peering, GCP checks
to see if there are any
subnets with overlapping IP
ranges between the
two networks or any
of their peered networks.
If there is overlap,
there's routing issues,
and peering can't
be established.
I'll try to connect
to the MySQL instance
from the WordPress instance.
Here, I've connected to the
WordPress instance using SSH.
After entering my route username
and password and the private IP
of the WordPress instance,
I can run the command
to view all available databases
and confirm that the connection
is successful.
And that's it.
We can confirm VPC
peering is established,
and the two instances
in the different VPCs
are communicating
over private IPs.
As you can see, VPC
peering gives you
security, performance,
and manageability.
To learn more, check out the
documentation linked below,
stay tuned for the next
episode, and remember,
optimizing your network means
freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]